babe got a brand new hour of stand-up
material April 12th in Austin at the
Paramount Theater is sold out the only
tickets we have left are April 13th at
the Empire Theater in San Antonio Texas
May 5th Buffalo first show sold out
second Show tickets May 6 Ithaca has
tickets May 7th Albany all sold out May
28th Newport Rhode Island the second
show has some tickets left and then
September 22nd in New York Radio City
sold out September 23rd theater at
Madison Square Garden we have tickets my
big New York City shows I will not be in
the New York area other than those two
shows and Sydney Australia June 9th it
remains to be seen but buy tickets I'll
give you a full refund if I don't show
up christycomedy.com for tikiwickies
guys I want to tour with the Jokers
right now speaking of new episodes every
Thursday night at 10 on TBS and True TV
this week and April 7th we're in Seattle
at the climate pledge Arena April 8th we
have two shows at the Keller Auditorium
in Portland that second show there's
still tickets left that's coming up this
weekend and then we're going to Bangor
Maine uh three at the Wang April 28th
and 29th in Boston we got the Maverick
Center in Utah on May 5th the Bellco
Theater in Denver on May 6 then we're
going to Arlington uh we're going to
Austin Texas The Moody Center Sugar Land
uh that's May 19th 20th and 21st we're
gonna keep going going to Columbus we're
going to Cleveland going to Detroit
Minneapolis Des Moines Kansas City
Nashville Indianapolis St Louis it's all
up there we're also adding dates so if
you don't see your dates you just go
back and check we're adding it's
impracticaljokerslive.com for all the
tickets I love you God bless you
[Music]
hey babe
we're beautiful like hey babes in the
sky
there it is that off Melody hey babes in
the sky oh I like that Ryan sickler
everybody
Ryan thank you for having me
how you doing buddy I'm doing good man
you almost died I did almost I know we
were we were uh we were pulling for it
this is my I know I heard I heard there
was an over under and I heard some
people big money you were gonna die and
now I lost it all but DraftKings or
whoever sponsors us they saved us I'm
sorry that's the crack of window because
it's hot crack it it's it's like now
it's good to be here it was hot in her
yeah now
tell us Ryan what happened yeah it's
great to see you visiting the East Coast
yeah I'm here to promote my species as
much and and you could tell he almost
died because he's wearing all black
which he was dressing for his own
funeral but he missed it
he missed death I did I dressed in all
black all the time I gotta break away
from it me too even when I go like on
vacation to the tropics I show up from
the airport I'm in a full black outfit I
look like the New Yorker that just
stormed in yeah do you feel weird yep do
you go in a pool with water shoes
not the pool no pool water shoes pool
though yeah my dad told me last week he
can't he's happy they can finally go in
the pool at his housing complex in Tampa
because he just got his water shoots
yeah that's is that a problem that's
when I was a kid there used to be this
place I don't know if it's still there
it was in Pennsylvania called cadors and
it was an outdoor wall you know it yeah
you do not know yes I do serious yes we
know cadors I do yeah she's like this
outdoor water park had fountains and
stuff you could swim out to the Fountain
and get on the fountain it's like for
kids you know it's nice but the bottom
of that thing was that rough concrete
and your feet when you leave you know
what I'm talking about on the floor so
that I would wear if I went back to
cadors I'd be like we're getting water
shoes for cador
no that's not Tony situation he told me
he wears water shoes in the pool he's he
only because he doesn't like the way
that the bottoms of his feet feel I
agree on the sliminess of the pool and
then his my stepmom's response was well
you should you should be going in with
uh no water shoes on because you have
diabetes and if you can feel the bottom
of the of the pool that means you're
good you have good foot sensation and
that's a good diabetes check for you oh
wow and my dad said I'm not doing it I'm
not getting I'm not going anywhere
without water shoes my dad is the type
of guy in the summertime whether he's
going to be in a water environment or
not he wears water shoes if you know
what though I'm thinking about your dad
now your dad served time yeah this might
be a prison thing it might be a prison
in this dirty [__] showers pools in
the prisons were probably disgusting
we know when the prisoners out there
doing laps
the water yeah I bet I bet that's a
shower [__] prison thing flops in the
shower and you're just scared to [__]
touch the bottoms of [__] if I went to
prison I would wear uh water shoes that
then extended up to my whole body yeah
right in the shower I wear a wetsuit in
the shower you know what's interesting
but I have a I have the buttons in the
back case somebody wanted access right
so well I just don't want to get wet you
know what's interesting is we got three
you know men here right we're all
different ages but all getting older
my father and I saw him uh this weekend
past weekend in Tampa Shout Out Tampa
did he get a spot he did get a spot he
did get a spot at the Tampa Theater he
got there early and he got a spot came
to see me couldn't get a spot couldn't
get a spot to see Sal vulcano got a spot
for me okay and he said we were talking
about he was talking about being older
and we were talking about just life and
he goes you know Chris when you get
older like he's like I'm 75. you know
it's not that you don't wanna he's like
you know when you see the the beautiful
woman
the difference is is you might if you
were you know single might talk to her
and you might have a chance with her he
was like my brain my brain says that I
wanna have sex with that woman
two but I then look in the mirror and
realize what I look like and also I
don't have a working penis
yeah he said he said so I just want to
let you know that as you age through
life your male brain stays the same it's
just your body falls apart and your
penis doesn't work but your brain still
thinks you can talk to that woman so
just be prepared for that what's the
oldest you think a penis has worked
without help
I know it you know it I don't know it
for sure
I don't know for sure but I think I
think I've told you this fact before
okay that the that the oldest that the
last surviving that the last person
whose father fought in the Civil War
just died like two years ago so there
was somebody alive two years ago who
could look you in the eye without
telling a lie and say my father fought
in the Civil War because what had
happened was is this man the father who
fought in the Civil War fought in the
Civil War at 16.
then had this person who just started
two years sounds like a show on uh uh
TLC on TL yes when he was 16 year old
Civil War six Civil War yeah when he was
80 when he was 80 he had a kid this kid
then this guy died at like 98.
so he was sitting there and back then
they didn't have any help for the
erections they didn't have any there was
no Bluetooth just like that by the way
no help with the erections no Bluetooth
and let's be honest I'm starting to
think it's a scam because I have a very
painful sunburn they had no sunblock in
the 17 1800s but yet nobody was dying to
skin cancer so what's giving your skin
cancer
where is George Washington's melanoma
right where is it you don't hear about
it at all no where's the Marquis De
lafayette's melanoma where's any of
their you know no actually where's
Ulysses that's Grand smelling my balls
off I don't think when was the first
time you heard about melanoma
the skin cancer companies made it up
right it's all [__] it's all a lie
just like recycling's a lie they're
lying to us I had a big talk about
recycling this weekend I apparently only
five percent of plastic gets recycled it
takes more energy to recycle it you you
it's worse for the environment to
recycle I don't have the facts to prove
that but I heard it well what I heard
was that the plastic bottle companies
kind of made it up so we feel like we
had to recycle to do their part right
but it's not doing it because they they
shouldn't be making plastic it's what it
is they push the recycling because they
want us to have peace of mind yes this
is what I heard yeah Brian you almost
died
I also feel like
um we're just the outside
dumpster I feel like we are well why
we're the outer space dumpster we're the
planet that's all plasticy and all that
like all these aliens that they know who
the [__] we are they're like that's that
[__] dumpster out there in that
Galaxy over there yeah it is killing
each other and blowing [__] up and right
it's true you know what else I heard too
the whole [__] like that they put on us
so like I'll reduce your carbon
footprint as a people individually it's
insane you need big action from all the
biggest otherwise they put it on you
they're like oh what are you gonna do
about your carbon fruit you're gonna get
a electric car you're gonna stop it it's
like individually it's insane we need if
we have we need any change we need the
majority the Illuminati global scale
yeah and it's not going to happen Factor
five live I'm seeing someone now that if
you didn't quit comedy I'd be seeing you
I'm I'm in physical therapy right now
whoa I'm just starting physical
therapist what happened babe take us
through it and then I want to take a
stance on gun control yeah great
um first of all go on
available on my YouTube now Lefty son my
special go watch that right now
my dad's the one that gave me this [__]
that I have which is what I can't come
to realize so and your dad's name was
Lefty yeah nickname of course and he's
no longer with it
but they don't live yeah wow so this
this is what I've all put together in
the last seven years so my dad died of
42 of a heart attack right we thought
how old are you I was 16 at the time so
how old are you now I'm 50.
you're in the clearance you look great
by the way listen I'll say this for a
comedian
because we're comedians yeah who just
almost died I look [__] good you
gotta throw those dude
I'm saying right now you gotta throw
those stats look at it you look better
than Matt Rife
I just went in for us all I did was go
in for a simple back surgery before you
continue where did they find on YouTube
what's your what's your oh Ryan uh r
sickler at Ryan sickler Ryan sickler.com
Ryan sickler on everything yeah it's at
our sickler on YouTube okay love it yeah
um
but I just went in for a back surgery
and my back's been [__] up since high
school that's what I thought was going
on that's what I wanted out I was
getting blown out and it [__] just
West Hollywood since high school what
happens man that's why it was right yeah
I mean we have to do what we have to do
in this career that's right we've all
got backs blown out yeah but our mind
was excessively blown out so I went to
go get surgery on it a surgical back
surgical black book a black blowout
um but then then it's not healing right
right it's ballooning up in my back so
like you need to come back in we got to
open it up and look at it they open it
up they say there's this like one
millimeter tear they fix it then they
tell me now you just gotta lay here for
a few days until you're up good to go to
get out of here in the hospital here in
the hospital in general population and
that's what I did I lay for days in gem
pop three days turns into five turns
into seven turns into eight shit's not
healing right turns into nine
and um and it's just what was not
healing that wasn't the millimeter Gap
wasn't closing it's 90 that closed but
it just the now you've had two surgeries
literally no pun intended back to back
and they're like and I'm like hey I'm
gonna receive that as a pun thank you
yeah how are you that's the name of the
episode I'm like why is this and you'll
feel this right now because the lady
goes she looks right at me and she goes
because you're not 20 anymore and I was
like yeah man I felt every bit of that
like I'm not right so it's taking longer
than it should the sirens are there
they're taking you back to the hospital
[Laughter]
nice
so uh anyway I lay there long enough and
I I have to pass the stairs test because
I have stairs to get into my home thank
[__] God that's what I used to do as
a physical therapist the stairs test
can't tell you how many people fail the
stairs test ready go
long story short I [__] go to pass
the stairs test and the lady says as
your occupational therapist I can tell
you that you have successfully passed
all the necessary tests to go home today
and then I [__] collapse on my bed
and I [__] feel it and I say I'm
clotting and she's like what I said I'm
clotting and then Chrissy D here [__]
tells a doctor doctor comes in tells me
my blood pressure is dangerously low and
they say you might be having a heart
attack and clotting and that that was
blackout that was death for me right
there I would have never known another
thing you lost Consciousness then
completely blacked out because they did
not they were not aware of your clotting
they were let me tell you something I
told every [__] who would listen
to me that I had it it's in all my
pre-op work it's in all it's everywhere
one of them even said man you're really
worried about that factor five and I was
like yeah cause I clotted I spotted in
2016. when I had kidney stones because I
was on bed rest but I didn't even know
what I had to keep them elevated six
months to figure out that I have this
they thought I had cancer they thought I
had leukemia they thought I had lymphoma
and they're freaking me the [__] out six
months they tell me no you've got this
blood disease but now it's genetic
everyone in the family needs to get
tested well my father's dead my mom
doesn't have it my two brothers don't
have it so I'm the only [__] that has
it well they don't have to be tested
because they're they don't have it but
my dad has it and I have it so now my
daughter does need to be tested when
she's older to see if she has it because
a pregnancy could kill her if she's on
bed rest it can affect men or women oh
yeah it wouldn't even matter if she
transitioned in a man it doesn't it
doesn't matter that blood's down
yes so uh yeah blood thinners for the
rest of my life she can't go on birth
control because birth control also can
make women clot right so daughter can't
yeah that you can't take testosterone
because that also makes until she
transitions then she can take tests then
we'll see it's still the same blood
though damn dude so so when you die what
but do when you passed out did you see a
light were you truly close I'll tell you
what I saw did you know you were passing
on did you have a thought this might be
it no so you just so so you're inside
you would have never even known it you
would have never even known that you
checked out never and that's it if you
felt an intense Rush of pain after the
United sense Rush the guy even said to
me what are you feeling right now and I
said I feel three elephants sitting on
my chest I've had this happen to me
before which I realized that in 2016
when they kept sending me out of the
hospital I'm passing these it's on my
own no medication no nothing so when I
wake up thank God I'll tell you this the
morning of this is a weird thing to
happen to me you got more blood clots in
Kingston
like that
so um
the morning of
it's like you don't sleep in there it's
like 4 a.m it's dark as [__] and I see
this black figure at the end of my bed
it doesn't look like a per there's no
detail but it's just a silhouette that
looks human-ish the silhouette and that
[__] thing reaches out and it touches
the right big toe of my foot what the
hell and shakes it a little bit just a
black figure at the end of your bed
shaking or touches it and then moves off
my right
and it just disappears were you dreading
it okay
peripheral I don't know what that was
what the [__] is that about I've thought
about it so much is that I wasn't a
doctor no it's nobody I'm like is that
my dad
is that is that death being like Oh yeah
this is all before I clot the morning of
all few hours before it goes down and
that thing though and it touched my
[__] foot I was drug free at that
point and it [__] shook my toe and
Bam floated off that way and I was like
you were drug-free and then and we are
not clotted yet we are hours away from
the towers away about eight hours away
because I caught it around noon
so then I wake up that's the name of the
special uh that's the name of the
episode clouded around noon and this
little this little Filipino nurse is
standing over me and I I I've been
saying this on all the podcasts I don't
know why I said this but I looked at her
I said am I still going home today and
she said no your discharge has been
canceled and I'm bummed I'm missing my
daughter canceled there's another good
name good name I'm missing my [__]
daughter I've been in there nine goddamn
days her mom's like what the hell is
going on I'm like I don't [__] know I
don't know they keep seeing and your
daughter can't come see you can't
so then I wake up they rush me to CT
scans they tell me my heart's swell
because they don't they want anyone
Under 12 in the hospital but when we get
to almost a month in I start fighting
that and they they let up on it but
right they said my heart swelled
um it was pumping 50 50. and that's big
because you already have the biggest
heart in comedy thanks man you really do
that's true what are the what are your
favorite two words in the English
language uh hello fresh yep I knew it
hellofresh or Spanish-speaking listeners
hola Fresca hello Fresca which is
America's
that's it and yes America's number one
meal kit
is uh hello fresh it's hellofresh and
guess what you want to spend less time
in the kitchen with quick and easy meals
who doesn't fresh it's Fast and Fresh
listen everyone's talking about the Fast
and the Furious I'm talking about fast
and fresh pineapple chicken tacos that's
right or Falafel Powerball is that
already in 15 minutes or less you can
get back to doing what you want because
you only spending 15 minutes in the
kitchen until you go back to your family
because everything's about family
everything's about family and
everything's about getting packed meals
packed with protein and hellofresh
you'll get that you probably live your
life a quarter mile at a time like
Dominic Toretto does well if you do then
you wanna you don't want to waste time
you don't want to squander time anywhere
yeah okay hellofresh is gonna let you
live your life a quarter mile at a time
you're not a pro in the kitchen they
have recipes you can learn right oh
whatever you want to do you're getting
seasonal ingredients picked up Peak
ripeness for Quality you can taste
ingredients travel from the farm to your
home in less than seven days so you know
they fresh and all you got to do right
now is give again this company we say it
every single time we don't know how they
make money because they give so much
stuff away for free and it is amazing
and if you're not using our promo code I
don't know what you're using go to
hellofresh.com hey babe50 and use the
code hey babe 50 for 50 off plus your
first box ships free what is it again
Sal you go to hellofresh.com hey babe
five zero and you use hey babe five zero
for fifty percent off first uh plus the
first box is going to ship free
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
used it last night did you use doordash
last night swear to God what'd you get I
ordered from a place that we order from
okay I won't say it and I got a I got a
a stuffed artichoke I don't know where
it is chicken colored parm and I got a
straw to tell the soup how do you like
that the fact that doordash is now
delivering straw shatella is amazing
it's all you need to know we love it
doordash this is a revolutionary app you
just order from anywhere that you want
you can get groceries too whatever you
support mom and pop stores it's not just
these major although they do have
everything everybody's wine you want
food delivered to your door by touching
a few buttons you download the doordash
app and you revolutionize your life and
the way that you find and procure food
yes and how about this for any of a
better value now you could save on all
your grocery and restaurant favorites
for the zero dollar delivery fee on
eligible orders with a dash pass
membership you can get a membership to
doordash I would suggest it because it
just saves you money yeah like I said
you can also just get groceries if you
need them thousands of grocery stores to
choose from they deliver exactly how you
want it and you could have substitutions
in the app if you needed as well
whatever yeah get 50 off your first door
Dash order up to a twenty dollar value
when you use the code hey babe 2023
that's hey Vape 2023 yeah at checkout
limited time offer terms apply 50 off up
to twenty dollar no Min subtotal and
zero delivery fees on your first order
we'll download the doordash app in the
app store and enter code hey babe 2023.
don't forget that's code hey
babe2023 for 50 off your first order
with doordash
former physical therapist and you did
all I thought I was going to do physical
therapy and I started and then I hit
human anatomy and physiology and I was
like it's a wrap on this and as a result
I like the class and I passed the class
I did I got a B in it yeah but then I
sent a kidney stone at the same time yes
and then I switched into
um Mass com and as a result of my early
days of PT classes I have a Bachelor of
Science in math in Mass com yeah I don't
have an artist I got a science because
all the [__] heavy PT classes I took
and I was like they're [__] so the
heart swell there's a big problem though
right do you know how our heart normally
pumps left and right that's what I want
to ask you yes so so
ventricle yeah your left ventricle fills
up and then it shoots chamber shoots the
blood out but it's two-thirds one-third
yes Left Right mine's 50 50 at this
point right now the left ventricle
that's the big one that's why if you get
a heart attack the Widowmaker they get
Colin Quinn's heart attack was the
Widowmaker but he survived it he wasn't
married five people yeah five people I
know had that that knock on wood all
survive but yeah I'm so scared of that
[__] but yeah so you're saying that
you're one third two third that's an
issue because now 50 because now one
side of your heart that's not designed
that's right one side can take it one
side cannot that's right so when that
happens so that's what's going on then
they tell me that my lungs are covered
in uh pulmonary embolisms and I'm
thinking one clot I'm thinking a clot no
no no no no no your [__] is massively
covered everywhere you look there's an
embolism and there's an embolism there's
an embolism everyone gets one everyone
gets one and then they tell me the
pulmonary embolism by the way is
terrifying and it's it can it can apps
it's a blood clot that breaks off from
your lungs and will just any it's like a
pinball wherever it wants to go well
you'll get a stroke you'll get instant
death you'll get a a a an
aneurysmal pinball it just the biggest
fear and they also said that you can I
didn't know this either that you could
just go in right now for a regular
massage that masseuse unknowingly can
massage your leg you unknowingly have a
clot it can break off and kill you I was
like 100 that can happen at a regular
massage dude that could happen when
you're in in the uh when the barometric
pressure changes in an airplane that's
why they tell you to walk all the time
it is we're all ticking time bombs all
of us so I have literally I have them on
right now I have to wear compression
pants when I fly I have to get up every
90 minutes I'm that guy in the back
that's stretching my quads and all this
[__] I go to the bathroom I'm marching
in there my father is the same way
diabetes compression socks and all that
and I I think you should think about
water shoes
there's a black figure wiggling your toe
touches me like this is gonna be a rough
day for you bro so then what happens you
pass out on the ninth day they tell me
that um I have the embolisms my heart's
swollen and now they say like you just
said it's touch and go for you you need
to call people and have real
conversations and I call people they did
not know I didn't know this extent buddy
I'm so sorry sorry I didn't there were
four surges that came in it was MLK day
and I was like I cannot die on it okay
I'll be a footprint I'll just be a
footprint yeah by the way are you sure
no Casey watching looking over here he
had a dream we have a dream don't go yet
so uh so uh oh my God yeah they tell me
to call I call my daughter's mother I'm
we're talking about life and she's like
what is going on what's your first
thought when you were when they told you
you could die what's your first thought
somebody get me my audio equipment here
I need to do a podcast yes I recorded
everything I recorded all those listen I
recorded every surgeon telling me I
could have died I record I should have
died I recorded every surgeon telling me
I could smoke marijuana they're like
that's the only thing you can smoke I'm
like yeah I can fly and smoke marijuana
like yeah they said it'll never bother
the the so here's another thing I didn't
know I you all right that's what I'm
getting out of myself so I have to call
you know family I have to tell my
daughter's mother like I might not even
get out of here they're telling me the
next 48 hours is crucial and they're
telling me this [__] like oh my heart
attack first they say and and clots but
then they come in and they start telling
me this [__] what you just said like so
you could also have a stroke and I'm I
hadn't even considered yeah I haven't
even considered stroke and nothing I'm
like always consider stroke I had a new
rule my room I made them write it on the
dry erase board stop telling me [__]
that could happen don't anymore it's
terrifying what I'm going through is
terrifying you're telling me I could lay
and now I'm waiting for a stroke what
about that it's contributing to the
stress of it yeah of course I'm saying
it's remaining in the present be in the
present so then could be an embolism
that kills you instantly that's right
FYI so I have a note on the board also
stop telling me I'm going home tomorrow
because they would tell me every [__]
day but then they test blood and they
see something they don't like and now
they're like well now we have to fast
for 12 hours so we've been fasting so
we'll talk about it test again and
you're there it's a two-day process so
every day they don't like something I'm
there for two more days and it just
turns into a month I laid I laid on my
back I never got higher than 30 degrees
this is higher than I sat all month
um I didn't [__] for at least two days
because all the pain meds really yeah
now only takes one or two pisses a week
it's convenient that's that's true
impressive yeah yeah I uh getting up out
of my bed log rolling Christy D knows
what a log roll is I had to log roll
over I had to sit up and make sure I
wasn't dizzy and pass out then get a
walker to go and pee to sit and pee if I
could do that man let me tell you
something that was the [__] New York
City marathon for me that was a
highlight of my day I was so stoked the
day I got to sit in a chair I [__]
sat in the sun I was like oh my God oh
my God this ordeal did you do you have
like a new appreciation for the little
things in life now yeah like it actually
has changed you listen literally sitting
here with you guys like is is so [__]
good for my soul talking to you like I
can't it changed me in the point that
like you really see what matters in your
life you know what I mean like we're all
in this rat race of Comedy we're worried
about content daily and keeping up with
the Joneses and the podcast and the
touring and this [__] promote watch my
special promoting almost died I hit my
out of pocket maximum already in January
Blue Shield silver that's not great
um that [__] and then you realize like
you have seen lately like you know my
kid I wanna I look my dad died when I
was 16. so I want to have that was it
ruined your sweet 16. it did totally I
wanted to have I want to have a [__]
it was like listen here it was at my
sweet 16 bro like Tommy Boy he dropped
right there at the wedding remember
it was like ah but you see it's
beautiful it's like it's like it's like
almost like that you know obviously you
survive this but it's like you've came
out of this uh like a like even better
guy than you were before I was always
like a great guy here's a thank you I
would say newer appreciation because I
journal every day the first day uh first
thing I write is gratitude it is good
every [__] day it took me it took me
this gay practice to get to glass half
instead of glass half empty like I had
to do gratitude [__] to [__] get my
mind to not go negative right away to go
positive so now because of my gay
journaling whenever some [__] goes down
the first thing I'll do is I'll I'll
high pitch it but I'll be like okay
yeah
like instead of like [__]
more days than not I do but I always was
grateful I always wrote every day for my
health and my daughter's health because
like I'm saying just weeks ago I'm
laying in a hospital bed they're telling
me I could die today weeks later I'm
flying on planes I'm sitting in a chair
right now I'm talking to you right it's
it's a [__] beautiful thing what
airline I flew on JetBlue and I got a
pod and laid down for the first time
because if it was like man Europe
have you ever been in one from Near
Death
I hope you ate it in your fasting window
um but dude it is it is one of those
things where so let me ask you that so
you go through this season your death
experiences all this stuff when is the
day when they finally tell you we've
gotten this under control you're
actually going home what did that feel
like and did you just run down the
Hostile punch people Young World Star as
you left that was terrifying okay
terrifying for listen the perfect timing
on that Bell oh my goodness this is all
over there none of this is it was
terrifying you never made it out of that
hospital
this is gonna be awesome
space dust and making all this [__]
up you know it's probably right so tell
us yeah I was terrified for a couple
reasons because this is exactly what
happened to my father he was in the
hospital had a heart attack Thanksgiving
he gets out we we give thanks that he's
alive we go home that weekend and that
Sunday night he dies and now I realize
because he died of this like we had to
put it all like it wasn't a heart attack
he really died of this Bloodshed clots
and never had blood thinners back in in
89 right he didn't have them
um
and I'm also terrified because there's
there's a button I can push and a team
of people come to see me immediately I
don't have that [__] at home you call
9-1-1 and an ambulance shows up and they
just they just get you settled to take
you to the hospital that's what all
these surgeons are telling me like I
said man I'm glad I failed that [__]
I've never been happier to fail a test
it's okay to fail a test I failed that
[__] test we encouraged that and if I
didn't fail that test I would have been
home a day earlier and I said man I
would definitely call 9-1-1 for this and
they said you wouldn't have made it and
I go what do you mean they go these
regular ambulance guys they're just
getting you to the hospital you would
have never made it you should have died
today they keep saying something's
looking over you in this room someone's
watching her are you religious I said no
I'm spiritual gay yeah but not religious
Catholic Church is literally gay yeah
yeah yes we're all uh yeah we're all gay
wow so I feel terrible that I didn't
know to this I didn't put it out there
to anybody I I'm not that guy the last
couple of weeks for Sal and I have been
like maybe the best weeks of our life
absolutely crushing it selling out like
you can't imagine like you might have
been scratch-offs yeah
just things cannot not go I really like
I'm gonna walk out here and get hit by a
truck I know we've been invest because
everything you just said is literally
the things that I conjure in my head
that I literally talk about in therapy
and lay down at night terrified
everything you just said how old are you
play book 46 okay good age it's a really
good age
how old are you play 38 oh you look good
too you guys look great well I just went
to Florida I got a sunburn yeah
it looks good
God bless man holy [__] dude yeah I I am
so sorry you went through it it's all
good you ready yes for ship stations I
love it dude that's the only ship I sail
on you have a small business or you're
trying to grow your business and you
ship things you need ship station which
is the aggregate of all the platforms
that can ship it'll save you time it'll
save you money you'll see we'll get
there the quickest for the cheapest
right that's it and if you don't know
what the word aggregate means ship
station will ship a book to your house
give you the definition the economy's
been a challenge you need every single
bit of help you can get especially if
you are a small business owner discounts
are up to 84 off USPS and UPS year I was
born 1984. that's what it is 130 000
companies have grown their e-commerce
business with ship station 98 of
companies that stick with ship station
for a year become customers for life and
right now all you gotta do is go to
shipstation.com put in our promo code
hey babe today and sign up for a free
the 60-day trial what is it it's
shipstation.com code hey babe almost
single dashboard you get it free 60-day
trial free 60-day trial rocket money
subscriptions rocket money try it for
free for 30 days it used to be known as
true bill but now it's rocket money and
it is a personal finance app that finds
and cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills on one place it's like
your mother
it is it's like rocket money is like
your mom basically you should send
rocket money flowers in May yes the
average person has about 12 paid
subscriptions do you know and I probably
have more than I actually did know that
that's one of the facts I know if you
think you're subscribed to only a
handful of services you might want to
double check y'all crazy over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to
720 a year I don't know what that is in
Australian currency and I'll never know
it is a lot of money it's a lot it's a
lot stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com hey babe tell them again
girl that's rocketmoney.com hey babe
that's rocketmoney.com hey babe do it
but I'm sorry you went through it as
well but and I know that you have we had
some crucial moments there but again
number one you're on the right
medication now so you don't worry and
you I'm sure you're staying in the
present now and not worrying about
what's going to happen tomorrow because
you just lived in something where there
could be no tomorrow that's right um
you're in the plunger the proper medical
care you're taking care of yourself
there's no reason to think that you
won't live a full life so I think
ultimately although it was scary and it
sucked now you can share the story and
maybe it'll make other people out there
be like just stay in the present and
live in the present you're right I wanna
if this is something I want to ask you
too because you're a medical guy
originally the uh I didn't know that so
the blood thinners they give me I
thought that would just costs are gone
but no yeah look at his nose thoughts
live in your lungs until your body gets
rid of them yeah they're still in me
right now I'm I'm a lab rat for the rest
of the year it's going to be a long year
and they're checking my numbers and
everything's trending in the right
direction which is great but they said
that there was this um surgery they
could do where they're like and it was
this is also touch and go like we don't
know if it's gonna happen I'm like I
don't want a third surgery in a few days
like we could take a a tube the size
your pinky we stick it in your groin up
into your lungs and there's this machine
they showed me a picture of it that
sucks the [__] clots right out of
your [__] lungs they said but because
you have that damn blood
disorder it can make you a vegetable and
brain bleed I was like then we're not
doing that then it's not even on the
[__] menu like yeah
unless they were saying if we don't do
this then you're going to be dead in a
day then you have to then you have to
but that's more of an electric surgery
so every day I sat there and had my
numbers had to go in the right direction
every day I'm like Jesus Christ please
go in the right direction and thank God
they did I don't have to do any of that
[__] yeah but blood thinners they it's
not it's you know there's it's not
doesn't happen right away it's it's a
process like intermittent days my man
knows what's up dude the intestinal
fortitude if I may quote gorilla monster
gorilla monster
it's something else man wow I I said if
there's ever a movie with Gorilla
Monsoon it's got to be you bro you gotta
put those blue tint glasses on and do
that [__] wow so now do you feel like a
day like today like sitting in the
present like what do you feel at any
moment you can you can be back like and
something can happen to you or you don't
live like that I there's a it's a good
question I'm not that big anxiety I
don't worry no but you shouldn't be
though I don't worry much about the
cloths I really don't worry much the the
first flight I took I just went down to
Austin to see Tom and Christina and
everybody at ymh and Rogan's club which
is great you should go if you haven't
been and I was more scared of the plane
crashing than I was my lungs popping so
I was like okay I'm in a right mindset
because there'll be a higher chance of
that happening the plane crashing then
your lungs popping especially being on
blood thinners yeah they told I had no
it happened they said you could fly the
next day said we don't recommend it but
you could fly the next day if you had to
and they had patients that had to fly
the next day getting right on blood I'm
like no way
um so that I really don't worry about I
feel pain in my lungs a lot but they
told me I'm gonna feel that as these
things move around and dissolve and [__]
so I just but they're not a threat no so
that's what I said I go listen man you
got to talk to me like I'm an idiot for
real like if I break my ankle okay and I
bang it I know that shit's gonna hurt
but I also know that pain isn't going to
kill me relate that to my lungs for me
please and that's what they did they
were like this is it it's not gonna so
um but with my back because I originally
went in for [__] back surgery but
once you almost die they're like [__]
your back we are saving your life now so
my back just literally sits there and
well it didn't it really didn't if I
don't go in I this is what they told me
over and over they're so funny the one
surgeon comes in and it's late at night
and he goes listen you did nothing wrong
nothing you come in yourself yeah you
tell everyone everything you did nothing
wrong your friend
the one who dunked and broke his arm I
start laugh I go how the [__] you know
no way who I am and who he is because
let's just say my brother's a fan of
Comedy I go okay he goes He stupid his
fault funny but dumb you not your fault
and I was like it's another surgeon was
Esty from the comedy
ha
huh
it sucks because I told everyone if they
would have just put me on blood thinners
while I was there for anything
I wouldn't have clotted like it's
it just became this whole unnecessary
ordeal it didn't need to happen at the
end of the day all these things led to
saving your life you want to know what
saved my life and I look at it every day
a tree what a tree this one particular
[__] tree I look at it every day I
always look at it at the stop sign I go
to my daughter I go that [__] tree
how you say F yeah nice
I talk real she's come to see I've had
to have her in a green room before
because I didn't have to have a
babysitter my daughter's got the earlier
eight yeah we should be having
conversations with our kids to just say
like they hear it everywhere else out
there my dad's different no my dad's not
different but
um
she wanted to go I'll pick her up from
school and she's like Dad can we go to
one of those neighborhood
um I don't know if you guys do this in
New York but they'll have a neighborhood
Library somebody'll put a little looks
like old school mailbox and you can give
a book take a book I've seen it just you
know what I'm talking about so I go yeah
we'll go get one and we go to this one
she mentions and I said Oh I thought you
wanted to go to that other one she's
like there's another one I go yeah she
gets this book we just got a puppy it's
about a puppy it's perfect she goes
let's go to the other one I go nah let's
just let's not she goes can we please
I'm like all right what the hell drive
over the element it's like two blocks
away and there's nothing in there she
wants she shuts it I open the door for
her like a gentleman she gets in the dog
gets in I go to take a step back after I
shut the door and there's this tree
that's got this this roots that are just
sprawling left and right why hit it with
the back of my foot and I start to fall
and I'm trying to catch my balance and
I'm tap dancing on the [__] sidewalk
and I look at my daughter I go Stella
I'm falling and I just and I hear her
voice like as I fall away she goes dead
and I just go on the ground this lady's
laughing walking her dog it's
embarrassing I get up and that was the
beginning of the pain I started feeling
I couldn't walk right I had to go get
another epidural like I've been dealing
with this [__] since high school it was
a high school injury but it just got to
the point when I was on I headlined the
Troubadour last year and I couldn't for
the first time in my whole career I
could not stand on stage both my legs
were numb I had to sit on like the edge
of a stool I've never sat on a stool
doing stand up before
um
yeah no big J action I'm gonna happen I
don't even know if I can do it I'm
starting my tour in May tickets
available Ryan sickler.com and um I
don't know Santino asked me that I was
like man that's a good question I don't
know if I could stand for I can do 15
minutes but I don't know if I still
stand for an hour stand for an hour I
don't think so wow
no because I really just started
physical therapy I just put I've been
doing all these new stretches and
learning how to like how we all Bend
wrong and twist wrong and they just
never bend over and flex and rotate do
not do that that's what everybody does
and you shouldn't be doing it they
taught me a little [__] like this like
instead of I can't even do it right now
but instead of twisting like we all do
to look left you should pivot your hip
ergonomics yep you should pivot your
hips
your legs straight and twist your body
like that but we all do right do it I
went I got uh what he calls x-rays pull
them x-rays right I I I call them X-rays
I don't know what you and your family
though he told me I had a curved spine
scoliosis but I don't know if it was
like scoliosis but you have a curved
spot no a lot of people like not like
yeah yeah he's called a kyphotic spine
okay yeah I got nervous and I don't know
if that's going to get worse or what's
going to happen that well what a shirt
to keep my posture here's what I'll tell
you and take this with what you make
it's not going to get worse I bought a
shirt that helps to keep my posture
that's right
that that's what we want I love it and
and here's what I'll tell you about a
kyphonic spine my friend it it may get
worse it may or may not get worse it
might or may not person that's walking
no it may it may or may not get worse
but when I will but what I will tell you
for sure yeah what I know for sure is
it's it's it's not going to get better
on its own so it will either stay put
where it is and you're never going to
get an inch worse but it's not going to
go it's not going to get any any
straighter so there's nothing I could do
right now to retract you could put on
that shirt yeah you could get a surgery
you could you could start stretching you
could start doing yoga it might be a
muscle imbalance pulling your spine out
of whack it could be a bunch of
different things jacked up it could be
that but if you so if you start with
just a little bit of daily stretching
Daily Yoga uh
can I just say what I want to say please
intermittent fasting okay is that right
all yeah because all that stuff all that
stuff you know you you drop weight all
the organs and blood flow start to get a
little bit better you start to put your
body at a mechanical advantage as
opposed to what we do on every day with
the American diet and American way of
life and a mechanical disadvantage right
is what we normally do okay so that's so
but or you could just you know you could
put on this this Mateo Lane compression
shirt he's wearing compression stockings
you can wear compression shirts Chrissy
compression um you know yeah yeah you
ever put one on oh my God
yeah we all have horrific posture I have
horrible I have the worst posture I
would be that's the other thing Olympics
you have to be honest all the time
you're a gold medalist in the worst
posture Olympics gotta be I think about
it a little time yeah I catch myself I'm
gonna go like this yeah and it only
lasts a couple of seconds yeah I used to
have I used to have a um like a mohawk
and I would like Let It spike out and
there's a picture of me just sitting
there normally like this and I look like
a Triceratops because we're like it's
just like spikes and my head is like
that
who has good posture and what do they do
to get it vanity has got good posture I
was called I had scoliosis I had to wear
back brace and she's got good posture
and that's very noticeable I mean
and he told me like it doesn't matter if
your shoulders are back it just your
mind has to be sure
yeah we also all of us have pretty big
heads so when you have a the bigger your
head yeah the bigger your head the you
typically the worst posture vanity has a
small head yeah you do
listen Divinity as a normal thing is
that true about it the heads that
because what the heads and and again our
American way of life with texting and
constantly being a crunched over
position that all ass and kyphotic Spine
and these issues also isn't it just bad
for our like the inner like there are
yeah stress all that yeah we're all
hunched over like this everything we do
is smaller and smaller and the only way
really way to get at they did a study
that I saw that people who got rid of
their smartphones they did a whole case
out I don't know if it was in the United
States but people got rid of their
smartphones it was a posture study wow
that their posture their kyphotics spine
went more to neutral in like 80 percent
of the people yeah these effective
smartphone smart
respiratory function even breathing
people are getting like a lump back here
now because we're looking down so much
at our phones people are starting to
grow it and you're getting that lump
there getting a lump on the back of your
neck yeah I get it too yeah sometimes
I'll put my head all the way back and
it'll get to a thing and then it like
folds back because there's a lump there
you're right about the head though man
my my
like
more my neck was more sore than my back
when I is it your neck your back or your
[__] on your crack tell us with all of
my neck my back my [__] and my crack
yeah from laying for 30 days I didn't
realize how much atrophy it happened in
my neck and my big ass head is just
sitting on this [__] stick and then
also podcasting like I I literally had
recorded enough episodes just because I
thought I'd just be doing minimum rehab
in January and I wanted to take time off
thank God I did it right up to the point
where I was on a walker when I got out I
went and recorded a patreon because
those people pay for it and it matters
to me that they pay money and I'm
sitting there and I can't figure out why
the [__] my neck is so sore and then I
realize I feel my own shoulders just
because I haven't held them up just
pulling my neck down in my head sitting
through my neck has hurt way more than
my [__] back during all this [__]
yeah no dude it's you came out the other
side and now it's almost like if you
don't go follow him on YouTube and get
his best special you're like a real
piece of [__] you're actually a piece of
[__] if you don't right on YouTube for
free yeah yeah I mean directions
I've been working I've been producing as
I've been writing and producing and
doing comedy for 20 [__] years I've
worked for ABC Family Fox Family
wbcw Fox Sports Oprah I met and worked
with Oprah when she launched her network
I directed and produced for stuff for
her no [__] yeah I'm Meadow wow you
think if Kelly gets her neck back and
[__] licked but not her crack she's
disappointed yes she needs all of them
I've been back to eating ass really back
to it you you you you abandoned it I
wasn't doing it but now I'm back here
it feels good because what made you what
what caused it to change just kind of
wanted to kind of
take on like you know hit that different
gear of life and say you know we're all
out here you know we're all here you
know as we are sucking titties and and
all that but I said what about the S and
so you know I can't forget about it I've
been back eating ass this is I even got
my own which was a nice surprise wow I
didn't hate it you had to prep for that
though actually no it's going block no I
think the way to do it is Kamikaze and I
was Kamikaze with it with the tongue in
the ass
wow not bad though I was clean which is
which I feel like that's the only thing
that happened in any shape or form
either you need a direction unless
there's like a two-day spa day going
right right you have to prepare for it
[Music]
I don't know
that I have never really thought about
uh wow wow all right well yeah okay okay
I mean again if I can't stress this
enough what an absolute garbage human
you'd be if you don't go watch Sickler's
special after literally the the life
that he's had hearing the story out
hearing this story and then you're still
gonna not do it is I mean a little
absurd I honestly think you watch it and
then you hit the thing and it plays
again yes I have a question what advice
do you have uh for someone who's trapped
in a hospital bed like now and there's
no hope no hope meaning there's no light
at the end of the tunnel they're not
giving them the go-ahead the only hope
is obviously you're a limo watch my
specials in addition to watch online
special of course hey babe here every
you might only have one Thursday left
but make sure it's hey babe
we're also touring
impactfulstrokerslive.com coming to a
city in the Au Kristy comedy he's all
over the world on the road and we do all
the things coming up Outlets yeah wow
dude wow so what is it so what would be
the advice I'll give advice for this for
anyone in a hospital period how about
that yes
um be an advocate for yourself because
I'm telling you our [__] we could go
on and on we're not going to our Health
Care system is broken and there are such
good people out there like I would say
of like if I dealt with a hundred people
in that whole scenario four or more
[__] I mean they were really good
people they're good nurses doctors out
there right now but you don't see the
same one like in my situation like it'll
be a girl coming in from Queens and the
next day it's Brooklyn and the next day
it's Jersey and you're like man you got
to tell your story over and over and
you're just a grain of sand on a beach
right they don't remember oh [__] I'm
sorry I gave you the wrong meds I I was
[__] Chris's at the hospital over
here everybody in the hospital
yeah everybody yeah to them it's just a
job and that doesn't mean they're bad
people
being advocate for yourself is huge
because a lot of people just give the
trust and faith to the doctor and the
doctors are all highly qualified they're
all insanely intelligent they all went
to medical school but when you are going
through what you're going through I'd
argue that you know more about your
condition knows more about your
condition because your it is everything
to you it's not everything to them so
whatever you've Googled whatever you
research you at least repeated to the
doctor and say I you have to show the
doctors everywhere I learned a sense of
physical therapist you have to show them
that you know a lot about your condition
and they will not [__] foot around that
they will say oh so and so knows what's
up so now I got to be on my game because
if you're just like do whatever then
that's what they're going to do is just
do whatever because they really don't
care about you and that doesn't mean
they're bad people it really doesn't
they just don't care at all because you
whatever you're going through they deal
with it every [__] day is an assembly
line that they don't give a [__] you
care that's right you being an advocate
is like that's the best advice I had to
argue with a few people like you know
sometimes they [__] up oh we forgot to
give you your meds I'm like that's the
med the blood thinner I need to stay
alive right now that's the one you can't
you're like okay Filipino for you for
you right right that's the last time I
was in the hospital that's why I was in
there what happened I had [__] foot you
had [__] foot yeah dude that that and
that's dangerous yeah really yeah you
know it would have prevented that right
water shoes
there it is your dad doesn't want to be
[__] footing around I mean it's
literally if just for that bit if you
don't listen to the special you're an
[__] when things get tied together
like that come on [__] foot water foot
[__] foot uh water shoe joke I will say
this is making me hopeful I'm super
relieved and happy and elated for you
being out of here right now
um and but I will say as well I I I'm
the I'm I'm a person that I was a
warrior and that's bad because that's
bad it just kind of you can't have that
kind of stress and it's always on it I
uh I'm walking out of this one even more
scared about everything in life
do you go get a yearly physical
Sal listen to me you're in your 40s yeah
get a yearly you know how many times I
go dude I'm close to the 60 than 30.
I've been I go twice a year and have
been since 20s I go twice a year I pay
for physical yeah you go to the dentist
I go to the dentist now I got physicals
yup fizzle twice a year bro I get
physicals yeah that's right I don't even
get physical I go twice a year and have
for for 20 some years because I've been
on cholesterol and blood pressure so I
make sure I get my blood tested so it's
not [__] with my kidneys and my liver
I go and it's worth it like I look at it
like this like I smoke marijuana right
if I'm gonna spend 200 on marijuana I
can spend 200 on going to see my [__]
doctor and getting prescriptions and
blood checked and you know look at that
like that like I spent 150 bucks on
Sushi two of those meals is your doctor
appointment whatever go invest in your
body there's a great internally
there's a great uh service called
forward I don't know if you know they
have them in L.A they have them in La
Chicago San Fran and New York it's
basically you basically pay a membership
like you pay to a gym it's like 125 a
month but it's to a team of doctors oh
so everything you want they're up
they're they're emailing me all the like
there when I go and get my blood work
this is how you do it it's how I do it
oh they pull it up on like a digital
screen like like I'm a robot they're
like this and that and they'll show you
like your blood and what uh you know uh
like sleep studies anything that you
need they schedule for you and then you
go and then and then the service you
belong to it's a fast forward yeah I
didn't want to talk about it until now
well that's when you should when you
feel comfortable when you should do it
I'm not going to fall I need a sleep
study but I can get this as a monthly
membership and I have a team working for
me basically yep look become a member
and they have all different plans so I'm
sorry so you don't have a doctor no you
can go to like you have a piece a
primary care yes it's I just it's it's
one of the doctors from forward oh okay
but it's a team of them oh so you go you
just go to whoever's in network with
forward you pay forward I pay forward
but you still have to have health
insurance this is a this is a boutiques
this is a service yeah but the thing is
is you have access to them 24 7 365. so
if I message them right now and was like
hey
um you know I I'm not feeling good or I
need this right that you know you get an
appointment immediately and you go in in
anything that you want is just
and the Advanced Diagnostics like
genetic analysis so they will do skin
cancer screening which we we're not sure
if it's real or not we're not sure if
the sunblock companies made that up
could be either one so so but what we
what they do is like they will give you
from a gin like they tailor your health
for you so like you get that genetic
analysis it tells you what you're
predisposed for all these things that
you might be in line for and then boom
that's how that's how they give you the
most Optimal Care for you you're not
just you're not just in an assembly line
when did you find this and how long
you've been doing it four years okay but
I've I've not went as regularly as I
should because I also get scared so you
do have to go
when where they have an up well in New
York they have one on Broadway they have
one in downtown brick and mortar forward
yeah yeah there's doctors in it yeah oh
yeah yeah it's a team of doctors you go
in they do a body scan blood pressure
like everything is like oh it's not all
digital see I didn't know that either
you are going to eventually go see a
human no you do that that's when they
pull up all my stuff on like a TV screen
on a monitor it's I'm in the office with
the doctor
they're taking a little blood and then
boom they get you get Ever the results
within five minutes so you don't have a
primary care physician I do one of the
doctors fast forward yes okay yes
and I'm going to say this too to your
audience because this is a big deal
there's so many people out there who are
strange from parents family members [__]
like that I'm telling you right now even
if you hate them figure out their
[__] genetic [__] [__] because
it's yours
yeah you hate them you don't hate their
blood somehow find out what their
genetically predisposed to because
that's your Gene code too but now with
modern science do a 23andMe or some type
of genetic testing and even if you can't
figure it out even if you're adopted
like Joe DeRosa you can you can find it
that's right is that right from that
from that that's what they did with me
they told me what I was I did at 23 me
for a bit on the show like I did for a
bit and then I realized later though
that like now I'm in the system like I I
didn't like that I was I thought it was
just like all right this is private but
it's not but my argument to that is like
if the government wants your DNA and
your fa they're gonna get it anyway but
what if like a crazy millionaire buys
the DNA and then clones you that's fine
then there's two of me that's great
I don't care at all I don't I'm you know
I'm waiting for the Blackboard
[Laughter]
the great uh Ryan sickler hysterical
comedian dear friend what's the name of
the special again it's called Lefty song
Lefty son right there
right now uh you can watch it for free
if you like it pass it on any other uh
yeah subscribe to my podcast the
Honeydew
um
please come back and uh yeah watch the
special like it share it you want a good
operation with the Honeydew thanks I
love him seeing what you're doing I'm
gonna [__] not run my tight ship
anymore this is I like sitting here
comfortably like this yes this is way
better slaves yeah with Greek slaves
yeah
love you guys love you buddy thank you
guys
[Music]